ladies and gentlemen dr. Anthony Fauci
as our country's top infectious disease
doctor and now he's the famous director
of the National Institute of Allergy and
Infectious Diseases as well as a member
of the White House coronavirus task
force everybody wants this gentlemen is
their guess he's very busy and out of
everyone he chose us tonight to speak to
which is a high honor thank you very
much for being here
Oh Conan I just want to say it's a great
pleasure being with you I've been a fan
of yours forever I just love you and I
love your work so it's absolutely my
pleasure thank you very much dr. Fauci
thank you now the White House is urging
Americans to wear cloth masks in public
to help prevent the spread of the novel
coronavirus reversing their earlier
stance okay they said one thing now
they're saying another do you agree with
the White House's recommendation on
cloth masks
you know Conan I'm not really dr. Fauci
I'm George Kira I'm the executive
producer of Seinfeld and Jerry samples
manager just so I think you're a little
confused when some pleasure to be here
George I'm not confused at all we
couldn't get Falchi it's not funny
George no it's not funny
he said no he turned us down he said our
show was inane anyone tuning in right
now thinks you're foul chief okay just
do your best you can do this George okay
doctor foul gee president Trump has said
that the drugs chloroquine and
hydroxychloroquine could be a potential
game-changer
even though no clinical trials have been
held our chloroquine and
hydroxychloroquine the potential game
changers that the president seems to
believe that they are conan this is so
sad
please stop please stop
could I get a free box set of the
Seinfeld shows not it
Tammy Fifi Saxonia please Conan thank
you for having me it's Conan just Conan